I can drive FIFTY FIIIIIIIVE!!
Because it's more efficient.
And safer!
Right?
Hey grandma drivers, this is big rig sciencepappy
Trace for DNews, what's your 20?
Old cars and highways often have a speed limit
of 55 because of efficiency.
It all started in 1973, when the U.S. was
under an oil embargo.
To conserve resources, Congress tied the state
speed limits to federal highway funding; basically
forcing states to adhere to 55 or else they'd
lose millions in highway money.
They picked 55 because the Argonne National
Laboratory found that was the speed most cars
would get the best miles-per-gallon.
Once the embargo ended, Congress was reluctant
to lift the limit, until 1995.
Afterward, States went on a tizzy trying to
pick new speed limits.
Most chose 70, but some use 65 or 80 (yes,
Texas, I know, you got a lil' bit of 85, you
get a cookie)!
But how did they decide on those numbers?
Well, firstly, exceeding the speed limit or
driving too fast for the conditions is the
primary cause of auto crashes globally.
Which is why we have speed limits in the first
place.
But it's important to know "too fast for conditions"
is a big deal.
Because speed limits are determined by data,
but the data is from three main things: nature,
engineering, and humans!
For example: when highway and traffic researchers
decide a speed limit they take into account
weather, visibility, terrain, location and
so on -- nature.
They also take into account the purpose of
the road, crash risks, traffic and truck flow
monitors (those two rubber tubes you sometimes
run over on the road), what the road is made
of, the amount of shoulder next to the road,
maintenance schedules -- that's engineering.
And of course how humans actually USE the
road which we'll come back to in a sec.
They then take that data and use different
computer and cost-based models to specifically
pick the speed for that stretch of road!
The human component has to do with safety,
but ALSO our ability to actually DRIVE on
that road at that speed.
The operating speed model is often used, sort
of crowdsources the speed limit using something
called the "85th percentile rule."
Basically, researchers observe the average
speed people naturally want to use on a stretch
of road, and lob off the speediest 15 percent!
Research has shown, that the 85th percentile
is a speed most people would be comfortable
driving.
Which is super important, because be it 55
or 85 the researchers and lawmakers want a
speed limit that is "accepted as reasonable
by a majority of road users."
So, nature, engineering and humans together
factor into our speed limits.
And that all kind of makes sense.
Faster speeds tend toward stretches of road
in Montana or Texas, where roads are open,
sparsely populated and straight, while dense,
high-traffic, urban areas with more weather
considerations tend toward slower speeds.
Duh, right?
Speed limits are human things, but they're
based on physics plus biology.
Faster speeds means less time for our animal
brains to react when something goes wrong.
According to the European Road Safety Observatory:
for every 1 km/h increase in speed there's
a 3 percent increase in crashes.It's an old
joke that it's not the crash that kills you,
but the sudden stop at the end.
The faster you are going, the data says, the
more kinetic energy is in the vehicle, and
the worse the crash is going to be.
This is why some regions likely have lower
speed limits for their conditions, roads and
drivers.
Once the speeds are picked, researchers are
constantly going back and adding new data
and testing the road at various speeds, and
in various conditions.
Look, everyone who drives a car wants to get
where they're going as efficiently, quickly,
and safely as possible, even traffic researchers!
Every road, and every type of road is different!
The reason that speed limit is on THAT road,
is a mix of lots of data, and lots of human
effort.
Sponsor Read
It also takes a lot of effort to keep your
car clean.
Techron by Chevron’s patented Precision
Clean Technology targets and removes deposits
left by lower tier gasolines.
It bonds with and breaks apart carbon deposits,
more effectively than other additive technologies.
Techron gets into the deepest parts of the
engine, where the most destructive deposits
built up, and sweeps them away.
But what about self-driving cars?
Should they have speed limits too?
Are they even safer?
Trace looks int-- wait a minute, I'm TRACE!
It's a good video, check it out. :D
What do you think?
Should speed limits be higher?
Lower?
Are you just waiting for the self-driving
revolution?
Tell me about it!